I'm in the office of Dr. LJ Drakovic, who examines dead bodies for the police in Pontiac, Michigan, and he's running through this carousel of slides, all of them murder victims. They're close-ups of body parts.
我正在密歇根州庞蒂亚克的LJ·德拉科维奇医生的办公室里，他为当地警方负责尸检工作。他正在播放一连串的幻灯片，全都是谋杀案的受害者。照片上都是尸体部位的特写。
To say, as you just flip through these things, this is the grisliest slide show I've ever seen. It's just like every slide is some--
怎么说呢，看着这些照片，这是我见过的最恐怖的幻灯片演示。每一张幻灯片简直就是——
Is another story, yes. Every crime scene is a story of its own, is a novel, and it opens up in every direction.
是另一个故事，没错。每一个犯罪现场都是一个独立的故事，是一部小说，而且它向各个方向展开。
To illustrate, he tells me this story. Back when he worked in the Wayne County Coroner's Office in Detroit, there was a young woman. This story, by the way, probably is not suitable for younger children. OK, anyway, there's this young woman. She apparently killed herself by taking her boyfriend's gun, putting it in her mouth, and firing. It was ruled a suicide. That's what the police thought. That's what the other medical examiners thought, but Dr. Drakovic wondered. This woman didn't have a history of depression. There's no note.
为了说明这一点，他给我讲了这样一个故事。当年他在底特律韦恩县验尸官办公室工作时，有一位年轻女子。顺便说一句，这个故事可能不适合小孩子听。好吧，总之，有位年轻女子。她显然是拿了男友的枪，塞进嘴里开枪自杀了。这被裁定为自杀。警方是这么认为的，其他法医也是这么认为的，但德拉科维奇医生感到怀疑。这位女士没有抑郁症病史。也没有留下遗书。
My colleagues tease me as being paranoid and seeing things where they were not.
我的同事们取笑我，说我多疑，总是在没问题的地方找问题。
So he does the examination, including the inside of the woman's mouth.
于是他进行了检查，包括那名女子的口腔内部。
In this particular case, the tongue showed two holes.
在这个特定的案例中，舌头上出现了两个孔。
Two holes, he says, is very strange in this kind of case because usually, he told me-- this gets a little explicit, again. Usually, he says, when people shoot themselves in the mouth to kill themselves, they kind of point the gun upward toward the brain. The tongue doesn't get involved at all-- doesn't get injured. The only way this could have happened, he realized, is if the tongue was all bunched up, kind of pushing against the tip of the gun-- the muzzle of the gun when the gun went off. But why would you do that? Why put your tongue there if you were killing yourself?
他说，在这种情况下出现两个孔非常奇怪，因为他告诉我——这又要变得有点露骨了。他说，通常人们开枪自杀时，枪口会朝上对着大脑。舌头根本不会被波及，也不会受伤。他意识到，唯一可能发生这种情况的原因是，当时舌头蜷缩在一起，在枪支走火时抵住了枪口。但为什么要那样做呢？如果想要自杀，为什么要那样放舌头？
In my assessment of this, this was a homicide. Now, do I know for sure? No, I did not. But that's the logic.
在我的评估中，这是一起谋杀案。我现在能确定吗？不能。但这符合逻辑。
So I told the detectives that that was my finding. They went back to interview the boyfriend, and they said, we know that you shot her. He said, no, I didn't. They said, yes, we know. The doctor told us. He said, what doctor? He says, the doctor that did the autopsy. He said, what autopsy? I called the coroner's office two weeks ago, and they told me they never did autopsies on suicides.
所以我告诉侦探们那是我的发现。他们回去讯问了男友，他们说：“我们知道是你杀了她。”他说：“不，我没有。”他们说：“是的，我们知道。医生告诉我们的。”他说：“哪个医生？”他们说：“做尸检的医生。”他说：“什么尸检？我两周前给验尸官办公室打过电话，他们告诉我他们从不对自杀案件进行尸检。”
Of course, you know, why call the coroner's office to ask that question if you're not planning on killing anybody? It did not take very long after that, he said, for this guy to confess. As Dr. Drakovic says, every crime scene--
当然了，如果你不是打算杀人，为什么要打电话给验尸官办公室问那个问题呢？他说，在那之后没过多久，这家伙就招供了。正如德拉科维奇医生所说，每一个犯罪现场——
Is a novel.
都是一部小说。
Well, today on our radio program, we dive into those crime scenes and the novels that led to them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And the thing that makes a crime scene such a strange kickoff to any story, any detective's investigation, is that the crime scene is filled with details, but it is totally unclear which ones are the important ones.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将深入探讨那些犯罪现场以及导致这些现场产生的小说。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。犯罪现场之所以成为任何故事、任何侦探调查的奇怪开端，是因为犯罪现场充满了细节，但完全不清楚哪些才是关键。
Years back, I was talking to this former forensic criminologist, Enrico Togneri, about this. And he said, sure, at a crime scene, there's all the stuff you would imagine from watching crime shows on TV. The shape of a blood stain can tell you the velocity and direction of the blood. A mist of blood means one thing. A puddle of blood means something else. But there's so much more, he said.
多年前，我和前法医犯罪学家恩里科·托格内里谈起过这件事。他说，确实，在犯罪现场，会有你在电视犯罪节目中能想象到的所有东西。血迹的形状可以告诉你血液的速度和方向。血雾意味着一回事。血泊则意味着另一回事。但他表示，还有更多细节。
Yeah, there's certain routine things that you would look for, and let's say you get into a scene where there's still some food on the table. You want to see if it's still warm. You want to see where the placing of the utensils might be. That might give you a clue whether it's a right-handed or a left-handed person that was last there. A smell could be important. You never know.
是的，你会寻找一些常规的东西，比如说，如果你进入一个桌上还有食物的现场。你会想看看食物是否还温热。你会想看看餐具的摆放位置。这可能会给你线索，判断最后在那里的人是惯用左手还是右手。气味也很重要。你永远不知道（会发现什么）。
If you can remember it, can you think of a case where an utterly ordinary object ended up being the piece of evidence that clinched it?
如果还能想起的话，你能想到一个完全普通的物体最终成为定案证据的案例吗？
Well, as a matter of fact, there was a burglary with a piece of cheese that had a tooth mark in it, and we were able to match the bite mark to the individual that did the burglary.
事实上，曾有一件入室盗窃案，我们发现了一块带有牙印的奶酪，我们得以将牙印与那个作案的人匹配上。
What?
什么？
Just a piece of cheese left in a refrigerator. The individual decided to help himself to some food, and he took a bite out of a piece of cheese. And he had a unique enough bite mark that we were able to identify it.
就是冰箱里剩下的一块奶酪。那个人决定吃点东西，就在那块奶酪上咬了一口。而他的牙印非常独特，我们借此确认了他的身份。
When the police are done with a crime scene, who actually cleans up the crime scene?
当警察处理完犯罪现场后，到底是谁来清理现场呢？
Usually, the person who owns the property. We would mark it as a possible biohazard, and then the individual would hire whoever he wanted to hire to have it cleaned up.
通常是业主。我们会将其标记为潜在的生物危害，然后业主会雇佣他想雇佣的任何人来清理。
Other drivers stare at Neal Smither's truck and sometimes take pictures. On the sides and back of it, in big red letters, is the company name-- Crime Scene Cleaners, specializing in homicides, suicides, and accidental deaths.
其他司机总是盯着尼尔·史密瑟的卡车，有时还会拍照。在车身两侧和后部，用醒目的红色大字写着公司名称——犯罪现场清洁公司，专门处理谋杀、自杀和意外死亡事件。
That's Nancy Updike, and this is Act 1 of our program. Act 1-- Grime Scene. Back when we first broadcast today's program-- this was a few years back-- Nancy went to a town near San Francisco to see Neal Smither, who cleans up crime scenes for a living. Quick warning-- some of this might not be suitable for younger listeners, the squeamish, and wimps. Also, we have unbeeped the curse words here in the podcast. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, it's at our website.
那是南希·厄普代克，这是我们节目的第一幕。第一幕——污秽现场。当年我们首次播出今天的节目时——那已经是几年前的事了——南希去了旧金山附近的一个小镇，见到了靠清理犯罪现场为生的尼尔·史密瑟。温馨提示——部分内容可能不适合年幼听众、胆小者及懦弱者。另外，我们在播客中没有对脏话消音。如果你更喜欢有消音的版本，请移步我们的网站。
After spending two days with Neal Smither, I was this close to signing up to open his Los Angeles franchise. I'm not joking. Neal spends all day, every day speeding around in a huge white pickup truck with a cell phone glued to his ear, making sure his company gets to dispose of every drop of blood within driving distance of Orinda, California, and his franchises in Utah, Kansas, Texas, Las Vegas, and Alabama. Mostly, he doesn't leave the truck. He's had this one for about a year, and it's got 90,000 miles on it. Neal is absolutely blunt about his job, to the point of crassness.
在尼尔·史密瑟身边待了两天后，我差点就签约要开一家洛杉矶分店了。我没开玩笑。尼尔整天整天开着一辆巨大的白色皮卡车飞驰，手机紧贴着耳朵，确保他的公司能处理掉奥林达市周边每一滴血迹，他在犹他、堪萨斯、德州、拉斯维加斯和阿拉巴马也都有分店。大部分时间他都不下车。他这辆车开了大约一年，已经跑了9万英里。尼尔对他的工作非常直率，直率到甚至有点粗鲁。
I did a job one time. An old guy dropped dead, decomposed on his kitchen floor. So when we got there, we had about a 10-by-5 foot square pool of just gore. No power in the house, so it's dark. It's very quiet. I'm in there with a respirator because it was just humming. It smelled. I'm hearing this noise, you know, and I shouldn't be hearing a noise. There's no power in this house. Nothing.
有一次我做了一个活儿。一个老头暴毙了，尸体在厨房地板上腐烂了。所以当我们到达时，地上有一滩大约5乘10英尺的血浆。房子里没电，所以很黑。非常安静。我戴着防毒面具在那里，因为到处都在嗡嗡作响。有臭味。我听到一种声音，你知道，我不该听到那种声音的。房子里没电。什么都没有。
I get a flashlight. I'm hearing this funky noise, man. What the fuck is that? So I get closer to the gore with my light, and it's just a bowling ball size thing of maggots, and they're writhing around in the blood and the gore, and it sounds like when you knead hamburger.
我拿了手电筒。我听到了那种奇怪的声音，天哪。那到底是什么鬼东西？我用灯光靠近那些腐肉，那是一团有保龄球那么大的蛆，它们在血肉中蠕动，听起来就像你在揉捏汉堡肉一样。
The maggots were making a sound that you could hear?
那些蛆发出的声音是你能够听见的？
There were so many of them, just so many of them writhing around in this pool of gore that, yeah, you could hear them.
它们的数量太多了，太多的蛆在这摊腐肉里蠕动，所以，是的，你能听见它们的声音。
The only time he speaks gently about what he does is on sales calls.
只有在推销业务时，他谈论起工作才会变得温柔。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hi there, this is Neal. May I help you? Yes, sir. Yes, sir. All righty. That's all you need to tell me. Let me kind of walk you through how we work. We'd have a crew to you within the hour. They'd write you up a free estimate. If you like the estimate, they'd rock and roll on that job right then and there. Our services are all-inclusive.
你好，我是尼尔。有什么能帮你的吗？好的，先生。是的，先生。好吧。这就是你需要告诉我的全部。让我带你了解一下我们的工作流程。我们会在一小时内派人到你那儿。他们会为你写一份免费估价单。如果你对估价满意，他们会立刻开始干活。我们的服务是全包的。
By the way, have you noticed Neal's southern accent? He made it up. He borrowed it from his Arkansas grandparents so he could play Steel Magnolia during business negotiations. He grew up in Santa Cruz. He has no problem admitting the accent is cultivated.
顺便问一下，你注意到尼尔的南方口音了吗？那是他编出来的。他从他阿肯色州的祖父母那里借用了这种口音，这样他就能在商业谈判中扮演“钢木兰”式的角色。他在圣克鲁斯长大。他毫不避讳地承认这个口音是刻意培养的。
Something about a southern voice, it just kind of opens up a trusting vein, you know, which is great. I mean, that's what I want.
某种南方口音，它总能打开信任的阀门，你知道，这太棒了。我是说，这就是我想要的。
Neal has that tightly wound energy, like Jim Carrey. He's 5' 5" with short brown hair under a baseball cap and sunglasses. He smokes Kools, does not stop for lunch, and drives way too fast. The directness, the crassness is all deliberate. It's his marketing strategy.
尼尔有一种紧绷的能量，就像金·凯瑞一样。他身高5英尺5英寸，戴着棒球帽和太阳镜，遮住棕色的短发。他抽Kool牌香烟，午饭时间也不停工，开车开得太快。这种直率和粗鲁都是故意的。这是他的营销策略。
Gore sells. Look at the truck. We're pretty up front. I hope I don't offend too many people. I just try to be honest with them, you know? I mean, we're dealing with death. How do you sugarcoat death? You know, you can't.
血腥味能卖钱。看看那辆卡车。我们相当直白。我希望我没有冒犯太多人。我只是试着对他们诚实，你知道吗？我是说，我们在和死亡打交道。你如何美化死亡？你知道，你做不到的。
Neal describes for me the outline left on a pleather couch by a body that has decomposed into it over the course of 60 days. And I want to stop here and acknowledge that this is gross. It is. It's gross, but it's interesting. And to me, it's much more interesting than it is gross. I mean, think of it-- a melted person.
尼尔向我描述了一具尸体在人造革沙发上分解60天后留下的轮廓。我想在这里停一下，承认这很恶心。确实如此。这很恶心，但很有趣。对我来说，它有趣的程度远超过了它的恶心程度。我是说，想想看——一个融化的人。
Four years ago, Neal had never seen a dead body. He was a laid-off mortgage broker, for God's sake. Then he saw Pulp Fiction. Remember that scene where John Travolta blows the guy's head off in the back of the car by mistake, and they have to call in Mr. Wolf to fix everything?
四年前，尼尔从未见过尸体。老天，那时他还是个下岗的抵押贷款经纪人。然后他看了《低俗小说》。还记得约翰·特拉沃尔塔在车后座意外爆了别人头，不得不叫“沃尔夫先生”来解决所有麻烦的那一幕吗？
Good. What I need you two fellows to do is take those cleaning products and clean the inside of the car. I need you to go in the back seat, scoop up all those little pieces of brain and skull. Get it out of there. Wipe down--
很好。我需要你们两个做的就是拿着那些清洁用品，清理车内。我需要你们去后座，把那些脑浆和头骨的碎屑都铲起来。清理干净——
Neal is possibly the only person in America who saw that scene and thought, wow, I want that job. And it turns out it is a real job. If someone dies in your house, it's up to you to get it clean. But doing it yourself, even if you wanted to, raises all sorts of problems. Are you complying with the state and federal laws governing the disposal of bodies and bodily fluids? Do you have the proper permits and liability coverage? No, you don't. So you call Neal.
尼尔可能是美国唯一一个看到那一幕并想“哇，我想要那份工作”的人。事实证明这确实是一份真正的工作。如果有人死在你家里，你得自己负责清理。但即便你想自己动手，也会引起各种问题。你遵守处理尸体和体液的国家及联邦法律了吗？你有适当的许可证和责任保险吗？没有，你没有。所以你得打给尼尔。
Here's how his job breaks down. Murders are the least of his business. Most of the cleanups are either decomps-- bodies that have sat for a while and started to decompose.
以下是他的工作分类。谋杀案在他的业务中所占比例最少。大部分清理工作都是针对腐尸的——那些已经放置了一段时间并开始分解的身体。
I did a decomp on the very end unit upstairs there. It was bad.
我在楼上那个最尽头的单元房做过一次腐尸清理。情况很糟。
How long had it been going?
已经腐烂多久了？
He sat for a good, long while. He was all humming, maggots everywhere. It was a typical decomp.
他躺了相当长一段时间。到处都是嗡嗡声，到处都是蛆。那是典型的腐尸。
Or suicides. Suicides and attempted suicides are a surprisingly big part of his job. The rest of Neal's business consists of meth labs and kiddie houses. Kiddie houses are those places usually full of old newspapers and other garbage that have dozens of cats everywhere, eating and peeing and crapping. Meth labs are usually hotel accounts. Neal has a few national chains on contract. Hotel rooms get used all the time to cook methamphetamine, Neal says. He does a lot of business with hotels. He claims, hyperbolically, that there's no hotel in the country that hasn't had a murder or suicide in one of its rooms.
或者是自杀。自杀和自杀未遂在他的工作中占了相当大的比例。尼尔剩下的业务包括制毒窝点和“猫窝”。“猫窝”通常是指那些堆满旧报纸和其他垃圾的地方，到处都有几十只猫在吃、拉、撒。制毒窝点通常是酒店客房。尼尔说，酒店房间经常被用来制作甲基苯丙胺。他与酒店有很多业务往来。他夸张地宣称，全国没有哪家酒店的房间里没发生过谋杀或自杀事件。
The second day I spend with Neal, he gets called out to a jail to clean up after a woman who tried to kill herself in the bathroom off the prisoners' waiting room. I'm not allowed to record anything. I have to just watch. I hold open the bathroom door with my foot while Neal sets up his stuff. Next to the sink are several thick, dark red drops of blood, and there are a few streaks of blood on the wall. Inside the sink is more blood. It isn't a lot, maybe a third of a cup, overall, but clearly, she did some damage.
我和尼尔待的第二天，他被叫到一个监狱，去清理一名在囚犯候见室旁边的洗手间里试图自杀的女子留下的残局。我不被允许录音。我只能在一旁看着。我用脚顶着洗手间门，而尼尔在布置他的工具。洗手盆旁边有几滴深红色的血迹，墙上也有几道血痕。洗手池里还有更多血。总量不多，总共也就三分之一杯，但很明显，她造成了一些伤害。
Then, while Neal's getting into his protective suit, a woman in the waiting room behind us-- a tweaker, Neal confided to me later, meaning a meth user-- reads the back of Neal's shirt out loud. Crime Scene Cleaners, she says. You cleaned my mother's house. Neal turns around. Yeah? Which one was that? Without any emotion, the woman says her mother and cousin were murdered by her mother's boyfriend a while ago. You guys cleaned the house, she repeats.
然后，当尼尔换上防护服时，我们身后候见室里的一个女人——尼尔后来私下告诉我那是个人吸毒者，意味着是个冰毒使用者——大声读出了尼尔衬衫背后的字。她说：“犯罪现场清洁公司。你们清理过我母亲的房子。”尼尔转过身。他说：“是吗？哪一次？”那个女人面无表情地说，她的母亲和表亲不久前被她母亲的男友谋杀了。“你们清理了那个房子，”她重复道。
Oh yeah. I remember that one. That was on the news, Neal says. The woman nods and doesn't say anything, so Neal goes back to cleaning. He whips through it in about 10 minutes, like it's spilt milk. In fact, it's exactly like cleaning up a mess at home, except with industrial strength cleansers and equipment. He snaps on some rubber gloves, sprays the whole area with a special enzyme to neutralize the blood and kill any bacteria or viruses, scrubs any tough spots with a little brush, and then wipes everything clean with heavy duty paper towels. It isn't hard. Just depressing.
“哦，是的。我还记得那个案子。那当时上过新闻。”尼尔说。那个女人点点头，没再说什么，于是尼尔继续清理。他在大约10分钟内就干完了，就像处理洒出的牛奶一样。事实上，这和他家里清理乱摊子完全一样，只是用了强力工业清洁剂和设备。他戴上橡胶手套，用一种特殊酶喷洒整个区域以中和血液并杀死任何细菌或病毒，用小刷子刷掉难处理的斑点，然后用重型纸巾把一切擦干净。这并不难。只是让人压抑。
Bottom line-- I'm a businessman. I'm an entrepreneur. I want to make money and build my company.
底线是——我是个商人。我是个企业家。我想赚钱，壮大我的公司。
Were you like this as a kid?
你小时候也是这样吗？
Well, I was the kid in school who would buy boxes of Blow Pops and bring them to school and sell them at lunch. I was the kid at school who ran a lunch ticket scam.
嗯，我在学校里就是那种会买几盒Blow Pops糖果带到学校去，然后在午餐时卖掉的孩子。我还是那个在学校搞午餐券诈骗的孩子。
What was the lunch ticket scam?
午餐券诈骗是怎么回事？
I had a girlfriend in the office, the head office in high school, and she'd kick me down with lunch tickets for a discounted price. And then I'd sell them for an increased price, but it was still lower than what the Mexican kids or whoever could buy them from the school. So I just figured I'd beat the school by $0.20 a ticket. Shit, I bankrolled my whole high school career on Blow Pops and lunch tickets. It was a beautiful thing. I always had money, and I didn't break any laws. Didn't sling dope-- none of that shit. Bought my own car and I bankrolled it with Blow Pops and lunch tickets.
我在高中学生处有个女朋友，她会以折扣价给我午餐券。然后我以加价后的价格卖掉它们，但仍然比墨西哥裔学生或者其他学生从学校买的价格要低。所以我只是算准了比学校每张票多赚20美分。天哪，我整个高中生涯都是靠Blow Pops和午餐券发家的。那真是太美妙了。我一直有钱，而且我没触犯任何法律。没去贩毒——没干那种烂事。我买了属于自己的车，而且是用Blow Pops和午餐券赚来的钱买的。
Neal's plan is to retire in seven years, at 40, and be rich. But in the meantime, the job is changing him. Seeing so many crime scenes, seeing the way so many people die, he's also seen how they live-- in houses filled with old newspapers, dirty dishes, and too many cats, never cleaning the bathroom.
尼尔的计划是在七年后，40岁时退休，成为有钱人。但在此期间，这份工作正在改变他。看到这么多的犯罪现场，看到这么多人死亡的方式，他也看到了他们是如何生活的——住在堆满旧报纸、脏碗碟、养了太多猫，却从不打扫卫生间的房子里。
I think more than anything now, most people are just dirty motherfuckers. We live like animals, man. You have no idea. I'm a clean freak. My place is spotless. So I was-- when I got into this, I was shocked by the way people live. It's amazing.
我想现在最让我感到的是，大多数人简直就是脏透了的混蛋。我们像动物一样生活，伙计。你根本无法想象。我是一个清洁狂。我的住处一尘不染。所以当我进入这个行业时，我对人们的生活方式感到震惊。这太神奇了。
I went into a bathroom yesterday at a car wash, right? Guy in there doing his business, and I walk into the thing. And you know, this guy had thrown his garbage on the floor and didn't flush the toilet. Just common-- no common courtesy at all. And he was in a tie and-- a clean-cut, nice-looking guy. Didn't your mom teach you anything, you 40-year-old dirtbag? Are you just a dirtbag? That's dirtbag, straight up. That is a dirtbag.
我昨天进了一个洗车场的洗手间，对吧？里面有人在办事，我走进去。你知道，这人把垃圾扔在地上，还没冲厕所。简直是——完全没有公德心。而且他系着领带，看起来是个干净利落、体面的人。你妈没教过你什么吗，你这个40岁的邋遢鬼？你难道天生就是个邋遢鬼吗？那简直就是邋遢鬼，没跑了。那就是个邋遢鬼。
Did you think people were this big dirtbags before this job?
在做这份工作之前，你认为人们都是这么大的邋遢鬼吗？
No, I had no idea. I had no idea. I thought everyone was normal. Believe me. The normal is the dirtbaggedness. Fuck.
不，我完全没概念。我没概念。我以为每个人都很正常。相信我。这种邋遢才是常态。见鬼。
But now, you see more dirtbaggery everywhere?
但现在，你到处都能看到邋遢行为？
Oh, it's 80/20 dirtbag. You bet. I swear to God.
哦，80%都是邋遢鬼。你猜对了。我敢对上帝发誓。
So now I go home and take a hot shower. Then I'll convert to a bathtub, read my book, and not think abou dirtbags, wait for my girl to get home. Wait for death. Death or my girl-- I love them both. [LAUGHING]
所以现在我回家会洗个热水澡。然后我会转到浴缸里看我的书，不去想那些邋遢鬼，等着我女朋友回家。等着死亡。死亡或者我女朋友——我都爱它们。[笑]
Neal's thought a lot about his own death in the last few years, not surprisingly. He says he wants to die slowly, so he can say goodbye to everyone. He doesn't want to be found by a company like his and cleaned up with his family off somewhere wondering what happened. He doesn't even care if it's a painful death, he says, as long as it's slow. Cancer would be fine, he says. He'd take cancer. When was the last time you heard someone say that?
不用说，尼尔过去几年里对自己死亡这件事想了很多。他说他想死得慢一点，这样他就可以和每个人告别。他不想被像他这样的公司发现并被清理掉，而他的家人却在别处纳闷发生了什么。他说，只要是慢性的，他甚至不在乎痛苦不痛苦。癌症就很好，他说。他会接受癌症。你上一次听到有人这么说是什么时候？
Nancy Updike is a producer for our program. We heard about Neal Smither from the book, Gig, which is a kind of unofficial sequel/tribute to Studs Terkel's classic book about Americans and their jobs, Working. Neal is still working. He has not retired. He says business is booming.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人。我们是从《Gig》这本书里了解到尼尔·史密瑟的，那本书是对斯塔兹·特克尔关于美国人及其职业的经典名著《工作》的一种非官方续篇/致敬。尼尔还在工作。他没有退休。他说生意正如火如荼。
Act 2-- The Police Cannot Do. So the clues at a crime scene are not always conclusive, of course. Lots of crimes are forever unsolved. People die, and it's never explained why. Stuff disappears and is never found again, though we want it to be. Fiction writer Aimee Bender has this story about a boy who would be handy to have around at lots of crime scenes. I have to say this is one of my favorite pieces of fiction we've ever put on the radio show. Her story was read first by actor Matt Molloy.
第二幕——警察做不到的事。所以，犯罪现场的线索当然并不总是结论性的。很多罪案永远无法侦破。人们死了，却从未解释原因。东西消失了，再也找不到了，尽管我们希望它被找到。小说家艾米·本德讲了这样一个故事，关于一个在许多犯罪现场都会很有用的小男孩。我必须说，这是我们电台节目中最受我喜爱的小说作品之一。她的故事首先由演员马特·莫洛伊朗读。
Once, there was an orphan who had a knack for finding lost things. Both his parents had been killed when he was eight years old. They were swimming in the ocean when it turned wild with waves, and each had tried to save the other from drowning. The boy woke up from a nap on the sand, alone. After the tragedy, the community adopted and raised him, and a few years after the death of his parents, he began to have a sense of objects, even when they weren't visible. This ability continued growing in power through his teens, and by his 20s, he was able to actually sniff out lost sunglasses, keys, contact lenses, and sweaters.
曾经有一个孤儿，有寻找丢失物品的天赋。他八岁时父母双亡。当时他们在海里游泳，海水突然变得狂暴，两人都试图从溺水中救出对方。男孩在沙滩上睡着了，醒来后就剩下自己一个人。悲剧发生后，社区收养并抚养了他。在父母去世几年后，他开始对物体产生一种感应，即使它们不在视线范围内。这种能力在他十几岁时不断增强，到了20多岁，他已经能够嗅出丢失的太阳镜、钥匙、隐形眼镜和毛衣了。
The neighbors discovered his talent accidentally. He was over at Jenny Sugar's house one evening, picking her up for a date, when Jenny's mother misplaced her hairbrush and was walking around complaining about this. The young man's nose twitched, and he turned slightly towards the kitchen and pointed to the drawer where the spoons and knives were kept. His date burst into laughter.
邻居们偶然发现了他的天赋。一天晚上他去珍妮·舒格家接她约会，当时珍妮的母亲弄丢了发刷，正走来走去抱怨这件事。年轻人的鼻子抽动了一下，微微转向厨房，指向存放勺子和刀具的抽屉。他的约会对象笑了起来。
Now that would be quite a silly place to put the brush, she said, among all that silverware. And she opened the drawer to make her point-- to wave with a knife or brush her hair with a spoon. But when she did, boom, there was the hairbrush, matted with gray curls, sitting on top of the fork pile.
“现在，把刷子放在那儿可真够蠢的，”她说，指着那些餐具。为了证明这一点，她打开了抽屉——想要挥舞一把刀或者用勺子刷头发。但当她打开时，砰的一声，发刷就在那儿，上面缠着灰色的卷发，正压在叉子堆上。
Jenny's mother kissed the young man on the cheek, but Jenny herself looked at him suspiciously all night long. You planned all that, didn't you, she said over dinner. You were trying to impress my mother. Well, you didn't impress me, she said.
珍妮的母亲亲吻了年轻人的脸颊，但珍妮本人整晚都怀疑地看着他。“你都计划好了，不是吗？”她在晚餐时说。“你是想给我母亲留下深刻印象。嗯，你没打动我，”她说。
He tried to explain himself, but she would hear none of it. And when he drove his car up to her house, she fled before he could even finish saying he'd had a nice time, which was a lie, anyway. He went home to his tiny room and thought about the word "lonely," and how it sounded and looked so lonely, with those two Ls in it, each standing tall by itself.
他试图解释自己，但她根本听不进去。当他开车送她到家时，她在他还没说完祝愿今晚愉快（反正那也是谎话）之前就逃跑了。他回到狭小的房间，想到了“孤独”这个词，它听起来和看起来是多么孤独，两个L字母立在中间，每一个都孤零零地矗立着。
As news spread around the neighborhood about the young man's skills, people reacted in two ways. There were the deeply appreciative and the skeptics. The appreciative ones called up the young man regularly. He'd stop by on his way to school, find their keys, and they'd give him a homemade muffin. The skeptics called him over, too, and watched him like a hawk. He'd still find their lost items, but they'd insist it was an elaborate scam and he was doing it all to get attention.
随着年轻人技能的消息在社区传开，人们有两种反应。一种是深表感激的，另一种是持怀疑态度的。那些感激的人会定期给年轻人打电话。他在上学路上顺道过来，帮他们找到钥匙，他们会给他一个自制的松饼。怀疑者也会叫他过来，像老鹰一样盯着他。他依然能找到他们丢失的物品，但他们会坚持认为这是一种精心策划的骗局，他这么做都是为了博取关注。
Maybe, declared one woman, waving her index finger in the air-- maybe, she said, he steals the thing so we think it's lost, moves the item, and then comes over to save it. How do we know it was really lost in the first place? What is going on?
“也许，”一位妇女一边挥舞着食指一边宣称——“也许，”她说，“他偷走了东西，让我们以为它丢了，移动了物品，然后跑来救场。我们怎么知道它真的是丢了呢？这到底是怎么回事？”
The young man didn't know himself. All he knew was the feeling of a tug-- light, but insistent, like a child at his sleeve. And that tug would turn him in the right direction and show him where to look. Each object had its own way of inhabiting space, and therefore messaging its location. The young man could sense, could smell an object's presence. He did not need to see it to feel where it put its gravity down. As would be expected, items that turned out to be miles away took much harder concentration than the ones that were two feet to the left.
年轻人自己也不知道。他只知道一种拉扯的感觉——轻微但坚持，就像一个孩子拉着他的袖子。那种拉扯会让他转向正确的方向，并告诉他往哪儿看。每个物体都有其占据空间的方式，因此也就传达了它们的位置信息。年轻人能感觉到，能嗅出物体的存在。他不需要看到它就能感觉到它在哪儿施加了重力。不出所料，那些远在几英里外的物品比那些在左侧两英尺远的东西需要集中得多的注意力。
When Mrs. Allen's little boy didn't come home one afternoon, that was the most difficult of all. Leonard Allen was eight years old and usually arrived home from school at 3:05. He had allergies and needed a pill before he went back out to play. That day, by 3:45, alone, Mrs. Allen was a wreck. Her boy rarely got lost. Only once had that happened, in the supermarket, but he'd been found quite easily under the produce tables, crying. The walk home from school was a straight line and Leonard was not the wandering kind.
当艾伦太太的小儿子下午没回家时，那是最艰难的一次。伦纳德·艾伦八岁，通常下午3:05从学校到家。他有过敏症，出去玩之前需要吃药。那天下午3:45，只有她一个人在家里，艾伦太太崩溃了。她的孩子很少走丢。只有一次发生过那种事，在超市里，但他很容易就在农产品摊位下被找到了，正在哭泣。从学校回家的路是一条直线，伦纳德不是那种会闲逛的孩子。
Mrs. Allen was just a regular neighbor, except for one extraordinary fact. Through an inheritance, she was the owner of a gargantuan emerald she called the green star. It sat, glasscased in her kitchen where everyone could see it, because she insisted that it be seen. Sometimes, as a party trick, she'd even cut steak with its beveled edge.
艾伦太太只是个普通的邻居，除了一个不寻常的事实。通过遗产继承，她拥有一颗巨大的绿宝石，她称之为“绿星”。它放在厨房的玻璃柜里，每个人都能看到，因为她坚持要让它被人看见。有时，作为派对上的噱头，她甚至会用它的斜面边缘切牛排。
On this day, she took the green star out of its case and stuck her palms on it. Where is my boy, she cried. The green star was cold and flat. She ran, weeping, to her neighbor, who calmly walked her back home. Together, they gave the house a thorough search, and then the neighbor, a believer, recommended calling the young man. Although Mrs. Allen was a skeptic, she thought anything was a worthwhile idea, and when the phone answered, she said in a trembling voice, you must find my boy.
就在这一天，她把绿星从柜子里拿出来，双掌紧贴在上面。“我的孩子在哪儿？”她哭喊着。绿星又冷又平。她流着泪跑向邻居，邻居冷静地陪她走回家。他们一起彻底搜查了房子，然后那个坚信年轻人能力的邻居建议叫他过来。虽然艾伦太太是个怀疑论者，但她觉得什么主意都值得一试，当电话接通时，她用颤抖的声音说：“你一定要找到我的孩子。”
The young man had been just about to go play basketball with his friends. He'd located the basketball in the bath tub. You lost him, said the young man. Mrs. Allen began to explain, and then her phone clicked. One moment please, she said, and the young man held on.
年轻人正准备和朋友们去打篮球。他刚才把篮球丢在浴缸里了。“你弄丢了他？”年轻人问。艾伦太太开始解释，然后她的电话咔哒响了一下。“请稍候，”她说，年轻人耐心地等待着。
When her voice returned, it was shaking with rage. He's been kidnapped, she said. They want the green star. The young man realized then that it was Mrs. Allen he was talking to and nodded. Oh, he said. I see.
当她的声音再次响起时，声音因为愤怒而颤抖。“他被绑架了，”她说。“他们想要绿星。”年轻人意识到正在和艾伦太太说话，便点了点头。“哦，”他说。“明白了。”
Everyone in town was familiar with Mrs. Allen's green star. I'll be right over, he said. The woman's voice was too run with tears to respond. In his basketball shorts and shirt, the young man jogged over to Mrs. Allen's house. He was amazed at how the green star was all exactly the same shade of green. He had a desire to lick it. By then, Mrs. Allen was in hysterics. They didn't tell me what to do, she sobbed. Where do I bring my emerald? How do I get my boy back?
镇上的每个人都知道艾伦太太的绿星。他说：“我马上过来。”女人因为泪水盈眶而无法回应。年轻人穿着篮球短裤和衬衫，慢跑着去了艾伦太太家。他很惊讶绿星的颜色居然那么匀称。他有一种想舔它的冲动。此时，艾伦太太陷入了歇斯底里。“他们没告诉我该怎么做，”她抽泣着。“我把绿宝石带到哪儿去？我怎么才能找回我的孩子？”
The young man tried to feel the scent of the boy. He asked for a photograph and stared at it-- a brown-haired kid at his kindergarten graduation. But the young man had only found objects before, and lost objects at that. He'd never found anything or anybody stolen. He wasn't a policeman.
年轻人试图感受男孩的气味。他要了一张照片，盯着它看——一个棕色头发的孩子，正参加幼儿园毕业典礼。但年轻人以前只找到过物品，而且还是丢失的物品。他从来没找到过被偷的东西或人。他不是警察。
Mrs. Allen called the police, and one officer showed up at the door. Oh, it's the finding guy, the officer said. The young man dipped his head modestly. He turned to his right, to his left, north, south. He got a glimmer of a feeling towards the north and walked out the back door through the back yard.
艾伦太太报了警，一名警官出现在门口。“哦，就是那个寻人专家，”警官说。年轻人谦逊地低下了头。他向右，向左，向北，向南转动。他感觉到了一丝往北的拉力，便走出后门，穿过后院。
Night approached, and the sky seemed to grow and deepen in the darkness. What's his name again, he called back to Mrs. Allen. Leonard, she said. He heard the policeman pull out a pad and begin to ask basic questions. He couldn't quite feel him.
夜幕降临，天空似乎在黑暗中生长和加深。“他叫什么名字？”他向艾伦太太喊道。“伦纳德，”她说。他听到警察掏出记事本开始询问基本问题。他无法完全感应到他。
He felt the air, and he felt the tug inside the green star, an object displaced from its original home in Asia. He felt the tug of a tree in the front yard, which had been uprooted from Virginia to be replanted here. And he felt the tug of his own watch, which was from his uncle. In an attempt to be fatherly, his uncle had insisted he take it, but they both knew the gesture was false. Maybe the boy was too far away by now.
他感应到了空气，感应到了绿星内部的拉扯，那是一个从亚洲老家迁徙出来的物体。他感应到了前院一棵树的拉扯，那棵树是从弗吉尼亚州连根拔起并重新栽种在这里的。他还感应到了自己手表的拉扯，那表来自他的叔叔。为了表现出父亲般的慈爱，叔叔坚持让他收下，但他们俩都知道那只是个虚假的姿态。也许男孩现在离得太远了。
He heard the policeman ask, what is he wearing? Mrs. Allen described a blue shirt, and the young man focused in on the blue shirt. He turned off his distractions, and the blue shirt came calling from the northwest like a distant radio station.
他听到警察问：“他穿什么衣服？”艾伦太太描述了一件蓝衬衫，年轻人专注在那件蓝衬衫上。他屏蔽了干扰，蓝衬衫像遥远的广播电台一样从西北方向传来了呼唤。
The young man went walking and walking, and about 14 houses down, he felt the blue shirt shrieking at him. And he walked right into the back yard, right through the back door, and sure enough, there were four people watching TV, including the tear-stained boy with a runny nose eating a candy bar. The young man scooped up the boy while the others watched, so surprised, they did nothing. And one even muttered, sorry, man.
年轻人走啊走，在大约14户人家之后，他感觉到蓝衬衫在向他尖叫。他直接走进后院，直接穿过后门，果然，有四个人在看电视，包括那个脸上挂着泪痕、鼻涕直流、正在吃巧克力棒的孩子。年轻人抱起孩子，而其他人看着，如此惊讶，竟什么也没做。其中一个甚至咕哝了一句：“抱歉，哥们。”
For 14 houses back, the young man held Leonard in his arms like a bride. Leonard stopped sneezing and looked up at the stars, and the young man smelled Leonard's hair, rich with the memory of peanut butter. He hoped Leonard would ask him a question-- any question. But Leonard was quiet. The young man answered in his head. Son, he said to himself, and the word rolled around, a marble on a marble floor. Son, he wanted to say.
在返回的那14户人家的路上，年轻人像抱新娘一样抱着伦纳德。伦纳德停止了打喷嚏，抬头看着星星，年轻人闻到了伦纳德头发的味道，那是充满花生酱记忆的香气。他希望伦纳德能问他一个问题——任何问题。但伦纳德很安静。年轻人就在脑海里回答了。儿子，他对自己说，这个词翻滚着，像大理石地板上的一颗弹珠。“儿子，”他想说。
When he reached Mrs. Allen's door, which was wide open, he walked in with quiet Leonard, and Mrs. Allen promptly burst into tears, and the policeman slunk out the door. She thanked the young man 1,000 times, even offered him the green star, but he refused it. Leonard turned on the TV and curled up on the sofa. The young man walked over and asked him about the program he was watching, but Leonard stuck his thumb in his mouth and didn't respond. Feel better, he said softly.
当他到达艾伦太太那扇敞开的门口时，他带着安静的伦纳德走了进去，艾伦太太立刻大哭起来，警察悄悄溜出了门。她感谢了年轻人一千遍，甚至要把绿星给他，但他拒绝了。伦纳德打开电视，蜷缩在沙发上。年轻人走过去问他在看什么节目，但伦纳德把拇指塞进嘴里，没有反应。“好点了吗？”他轻轻地问。
Tucking the basketball beneath his arm, the young man walked home, shoulders low. In his tiny room, he undressed and lay in bed. Had it been a naked child with nothing on-- no shoes, no necklace, no hair bow, no watch-- he could not have found it.
年轻人把篮球夹在腋下，耸着肩膀回家了。在他狭小的房间里，他脱了衣服躺在床上。如果那是一个赤身裸体的孩子，身上什么都没有——没有鞋子、没有项链、没有发带、没有手表——他根本找不到他。
He lay in bed that night with the trees from other places rustling, and he could feel their confusion. No snow here. Not a lot of rain. Where am I? What is wrong with this dirt?
那天晚上他躺在床上，感受着来自他处树木的沙沙声，他能感觉到它们的困惑。“这儿没雪。雨也不多。我在哪儿？这土是怎么回事？”
Crossing his hands in front of him, he held onto his shoulders. Concentrate hard, he thought. Where are you? Everything felt blank and quiet. He couldn't feel a tug. He squeezed his eyes shut and let the question bubble up. Where did you go? Come find me. I'm over here. Come find me. If he listened hard enough, he thought he could hear the waves hitting.
他双手交叉在胸前，紧紧抱着自己的肩膀。“集中精神，”他想。“你在哪儿？”一切都显得空白而安静。他感觉不到拉力。他紧紧闭上眼睛，任由问题浮现。“你去了哪儿？快来找我。我在这儿。快来找我。”如果他听得足够仔细，他想他能听到海浪拍打的声音。
Aimee Bender's short story is called Loser. It's from her collection of short fiction called The Girl in the Flammable Skirt. It was read for us by Matt Molloy.
艾米·本德的短篇小说叫《失败者》。选自她的小说集《穿着易燃裙子的女孩》。由马特·莫洛伊为我们朗读。
Coming up-- what does it mean when you get out of prison, kick your drug habit, return to the scene of your crimes, and little kids make fun of you? Kindergarten con in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来——当你出狱、戒掉毒瘾、回到犯罪现场、而小孩子却取笑你时，这意味着什么？《芝加哥公共广播》的节目在稍后的幼儿园骗局故事中继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- crime scenes and the stories they tell. So today's episode first aired years ago, but in putting together the rerun, we all realized here we did actually have a question about crime scenes that comes from stuff that's been in the news recently.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的不同故事。今天的节目——犯罪现场以及它们讲述的故事。所以今天的节目是多年前首播的，但在重新整理时，我们都意识到，关于犯罪现场，我们确实有一个源于最近新闻中的问题。
I am Bennet Omalu. I'm a forensic pathologist and neuropathologist.
我是本内特·奥马卢。我是一名法医病理学家和神经病理学家。
After Stephon Clark was shot by Sacramento police back in March, the county coroner did the official autopsy for the state. But the family also hired a well-known forensic pathologist named Bennet Omalu to do an autopsy for them. He announced his findings at this press conference. If you remember that case, Stephon Clark was unarmed, 22 years old, shot by police multiple times. Dr. Omalu's analysis came out before the county coroner's, and he was definitive about a number of things.
3月斯蒂芬·克拉克被萨克拉门托警方枪杀后，县验尸官为州政府做了正式尸检。但家属也雇了一位著名的法医病理学家本内特·奥马卢为他们进行尸检。他在新闻发布会上公布了他的发现。如果你记得那个案子，斯蒂芬·克拉克手无寸铁，22岁，被警方多次射击。奥马卢医生的分析在县验尸官的结论之前就发布了，他对很多事情都给出了确切的结论。
There were a total of eight gunshot wounds, meaning that he was hit by eight bullets.
总共有八处枪伤，意味着他被八颗子弹击中。
The first shot, Omalu said, hit Stephon Clark in the side and then spun him around so his back was to the officers. Then six of the eight shots were to his back. That is a different story than the police had told. Police had said he was advancing towards them when they fired.
奥马卢说，第一枪击中了斯蒂芬·克拉克的侧面，然后让他转身，背对着警官。接着八枪中有六枪打在他的背部。这与警方讲述的故事不同。警方曾表示，当他们开枪时，他正朝着他们走过来。
So the proposition that has been presented that he was assailing the officers is inconsistent with the prevailing forensic evidence.
所以，那种他正袭击警官的说法，与现有的法医证据是不一致的。
Weeks later, the county released its report. It was different from Dr. Omalu's report in some significant ways. First, it said there were seven bullets, not eight. It said only three shots were to the back, not six. And as for the first shot, the county said it was probably to his thigh and that Clark probably was walking towards the officers when it happened. And we wondered here at our show how could something so basic be in dispute? The number of shots, whether they entered from the back or from the front, does that indicate that one of the autopsies was deliberately spinning the results? Or are these actual, honest scientists simply disagreeing about the evidence that's in front of them?
几周后，县政府发布了报告。它在一些重要方面与奥马卢医生的报告不同。首先，它说是七颗子弹，而不是八颗。它说只有三枪打在背部，而不是六枪。至于第一枪，县里说可能是打在他的大腿上，当时克拉克很可能正朝着警官走去。我们在节目中纳闷，怎么可能连如此基础的事情都有争议呢？子弹数量、是从背后还是正面进入，这是否表明其中一份尸检报告在故意扭曲结果？还是这些诚实的科学家们仅仅是对眼前的证据产生了分歧？
Well, I asked Dr. Judy Melinek, a veteran forensic pathologist who does autopsies in San Francisco, and she said these kinds of discrepancies happen all the time when there are two autopsies of the same person. She said in these kinds of cases, the official autopsy-- the coroner's office-- usually happens first, and then the family gets to do their autopsy after that. That's true, even though the family usually goes public with their results first, as happened in this case.
我请教了朱迪·梅利内克医生，一位在旧金山进行尸检的资深法医病理学家，她说当同一个人的两份尸检报告出现分歧时，这种情况时有发生。她说在这些案例中，官方尸检——验尸官办公室——通常先进行，然后家属之后再请人做尸检。即便家属通常先公布结果（就像这个案子一样），也是如此。
So Dr. Melinek says, picture, OK, two autopsies by two doctors.
所以梅利内克医生说，想象一下，两名医生进行的两次尸检。
The first autopsy done by the coroner's office alters the body and changes the evidence. So it makes it a lot more difficult for the second pathologist.
验尸官办公室完成的第一次尸检改变了身体，改变了证据。所以这让第二位病理学家的工作变得困难多了。
When the second pathologist gets the body, it's already been washed clean, so it doesn't have any bloodstains or trace residue. The first pathologist has already cut open the body, has already removed the bullets.
当第二位病理学家拿到尸体时，它已经被清洗干净，没有任何血迹或痕迹残留。第一位病理学家已经切开了身体，已经取出了子弹。
So when Dr. Omalu got the body, he didn't have the bullets anymore. They had been taken out by the first autopsy, and he didn't have access to the x-rays of the body from the first autopsy.
所以当奥马卢医生拿到尸体时，他已经没有子弹了。它们在第一次尸检时被取走了，他也无法获取第一次尸检的身体X光片。
Which would have shown him where the bullets had been.
如果能看到的话，那些X光片本可以告诉他子弹曾经的位置。
He also didn't have the organs in their proper orientation in the body. The organs had been taken out by the previous autopsy pathologist and sliced up to identify the wound tracks, and then put in a plastic bag inside the body cavity. So the first pathologist has that advantage because they got the body pristine, and it wasn't altered.
他也没有器官在身体内的正确方位。器官已经被之前的尸检病理学家取出并切片以识别创伤轨迹，然后被装进身体空腔里的塑料袋里。所以第一位病理学家有那个优势，因为他们得到的是原始未改动的尸体。
In this way, Dr. Melinek says, there could be lots of disagreement, and it could be honest disagreement between pathologists. They are people looking at different sets of data, so they come to different conclusions. And with that, we have arrived at Act 3 of our program. Act 3-- Return to the Scene of the Crime.
以这种方式，梅利内克医生说，可能会产生很多分歧，而且这可能是病理学家之间诚实的分歧。他们是看着不同数据的人，所以他们得出了不同的结论。至此，我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕——回到犯罪现场。
You know, there's this truism in detective fiction that a criminal always returns to the scene of the crime. It turns out, in real life, that actually is not very common at all, except among arsonists. Arsonists apparently like to see the fires they've set, and then some of them are actually caught when police look at pictures taken of crowds at fires. And then-- OK, maybe this is rare, maybe not; nobody really keeps track of this kind of thing-- there are the people who circle back to the scene of the crimes to undo, to erase something, or at least to promise that it's never going to happen again. Katie Davis discovered that one of her own neighbors in Washington, DC, an old friend of hers, was trying to do just that.
你知道，侦探小说里有一句老话，罪犯总是回到犯罪现场。事实证明，在现实生活中，这种情况其实并不常见，除了纵火犯。纵火犯显然喜欢看到他们放的火，而且有些人确实是因为警方查看了火灾现场围观人群的照片而被抓获的。还有——好吧，也许这很少见，也许不是；没人真正追踪这类事情——有一些人转回犯罪现场是为了撤销、抹除某件事，或者至少做出承诺，保证它再也不会发生了。凯蒂·戴维斯发现她华盛顿特区的一位邻居，也是她的老朋友，正试图这样做。
Bobby comes up my street one afternoon in March. I haven't seen him in a few months, and he's kind of gliding along, smoking a Marlboro. That's the way he's carried himself since sixth grade, when I first met him-- one of the bad boys from over on Calvert Street. Bobby tells me he's going to coach a Little League team with some neighborhood kids. Great, I say from up on my porch. Inside, I'm thinking, who's he kidding? He's rail thin. He's sweating. It looks like he's been using all winter.
三月的一个下午，鲍比走在我的街上。我几个月没见到他了，他抽着万宝路，滑行着走过来。从六年级我第一次见到他起，他一直就是这个样子——从卡尔弗街过来的坏小子之一。鲍比告诉我他要带一些社区孩子参加小联盟球队。我从门廊上说：“太棒了。”心里却在想，他是在跟谁开玩笑？他瘦得像根柴。他在出汗。看起来他整个冬天都在吸毒。
Bobby flicks his burning cigarette into the street and watches me, waiting for more reaction. This is the same Bobby I loved and tried to save for a whole year. Bobby who sold $60 from my house to buy heroin and swore to God-- swore to his own dead daughter that my dog, Purdy, ate the money. And this is his latest plan to get clean? Coaching a bunch of 10, 11, and 12-year-olds rounded up by the DC Department of Recreation? All I can say is, that's great.
鲍比把燃烧的烟头弹到街上，看着我，等待着更多的反应。这就是那个我爱过并试图拯救了一整年的鲍比。那个从我家偷走60美元买海洛因，却对着上帝发誓——对着他自己死去的女儿发誓，说是我的狗珀蒂吃了那钱的鲍比。这就是他戒毒的最新计划？去教导一群由特区娱乐部召集起来的10、11和12岁孩子？我只能说，那太棒了。
A week later, Bobby's back, this time on my machine.
一周后，鲍比又来了，这次是在我的留言机上。
You have two messages.
你有两条留言。
[BEEP]
[哔]
Message one.
第一条留言。
Hey, how are you doing? Just calling to say hi. When I get off, I'll probably walk Bailey. See if we can both run up and see if we can say hi to you. Katie, you've got to see this. These thugs I got are unbelievable. One of them tried to spit on me yesterday at practice. A couple of them, I don't think-- I don't think even I can handle. It's like they're too much of a disruption, you know?
“嘿，你怎么样？只是打电话问候一下。等我忙完，可能会带贝利去散步。看我们能不能跑过去看看你，顺便跟你打个招呼。凯蒂，你一定要看看这些家伙。我手下这些小混混简直不可思议。昨天练习时，其中一个居然试图朝我吐口水。有几个家伙，我觉得——我觉得连我都没法应付。他们简直太捣乱了，你知道吗？”
[BEEP]
[哔]
My machine cuts him off, but now I know Bobby's clean because if he were still using heroin, nothing could puncture his detached haze. He's sounding awake and rattled. Bobby, who spent 2 and 1/2 years in Lorton Prison on assault and possession charges, rattled by a bunch of kids at their first baseball practice.
我的机器切断了他的留言，但现在我知道鲍比戒毒了，因为如果他还在用海洛因，什么东西都无法刺穿他那种超然的迷茫。他的声音听起来清醒而惊慌。鲍比，曾经因袭击和藏毒在洛顿监狱坐了两年半牢，现在却被一群第一次参加棒球训练的孩子搞得惊慌失措。
First day was just crazy.
第一天简直太疯狂了。
We went to Harrison Playground between 13th and 14th on V Street, and that's a rough neighborhood. And as soon as we got on the field, my kids started to act up right away-- right away-- and I think they were afraid. I was a little afraid.
我们去了V街13街和14街之间的哈里森游乐场，那是个混乱的社区。我们一上场，我的孩子们就开始调皮捣蛋——立刻就开始了——而且我觉得他们很害怕。我也有一点害怕。
OK, he was like picking who was going be right field or whatever, but then everybody was just yelling at each other and jumping on each other.
好吧，他当时在选谁去守右外野什么的，但然后大家就开始互相大喊大叫，互相扑打。
I tried to get them to chill, to relax and play ball, focus on the game. They started cursing me-- a few of them-- cursing me and cursing each other. One kid spit at me.
我试图让他们冷静下来，放松心情打球，专注于比赛。他们开始咒骂我——其中几个——咒骂我，也咒骂彼此。一个孩子朝我吐口水。
And he got mad and said practice was over.
然后他生气了，说训练结束了。
And I cursed them, and I told them I didn't-- they didn't [BLEEP] impress me. Before they were born, I was in the penitentiary, you know, so if they're trying to act like they're bad, they're not impressing me. And right when I did that, I felt in my gut that I had just screwed up. I felt right then that, you know what? You just laid all of your cards on the table. You don't have a whole card anymore. Now they know you.
我咒骂了他们，我告诉他们我不——他们[哔]根本没给我留下任何印象。在他们出生之前，我就在监狱里了，你知道吗，所以如果他们想装坏，他们可没打动我。就在我说了那话的时候，我直觉感到我搞砸了。在那一刻我意识到，你知道吗？你把所有的底牌都摊在桌上了。你再也没有一张好牌了。现在他们看穿你了。
Then Shannon said maybe he got pumped in the butt by lots of men. That's when everybody was laughing.
然后香农说也许他被很多男人爆过菊花。那会儿大家都笑了。
One kid says, well, while you were in prison, were you getting humped? And then I knew I had screwed up. I said, no, that didn't happen to me. Another one said, oh, because you were the humper, right?
一个孩子说：“好吧，你在监狱里的时候，是不是被人搞了？”那时我就知道我搞砸了。我说：“不，那没发生在我身上。”另一个说：“哦，因为你就是搞别人的那个，对吧？”
Three days later, they hold a second practice, this time at a field in our neighborhood. Bobby's back for more salvation through Little League.
三天后，他们举行了第二次练习，这次是在我们社区的一块场地上。鲍比又为了救赎通过小联盟回到了这里。
Shut the for I smack the shit out of you.
“闭嘴，不然我扇死你。”
Do it.
“有种你来啊。”
What's your strategy? Or do you-- maybe you're formulating it?
你的策略是什么？还是你——也许你正在构思中？
I'm formulating it, but my strategy, short term, is to-- my strategy is to remember I'm the adult. Break! Good stick! Go, go, go, go! Run it out. He might fall. He might break his ankle. All right. Good stick. Good hustle. Hey, every first baseman don't play as good as him.
我在构思，但我的短期策略是——我的策略是记住我是个成年人。“散开！打得好！跑，跑，跑，跑！跑出去。他可能会摔倒。他可能会摔断脚踝。好了。打得好。跑得好。嘿，不是每个一垒手都像他守得那么好。”
The second practice is going a lot better. The only tantrums being thrown are by the kids. Bobby stands by the backstop in our park, pushing away a locust sapling that's grown up through the fence. There are no bases and only a warped piece of rubber for the pitcher's mound. That's how it goes around here. Anyone with any money drives their kids to the wealthier neighborhoods to play, leaving this misshapen field for Bobby's team.
第二次练习进行得顺利多了。唯一发脾气的只有孩子们。鲍比站在我们公园的挡球网旁，推开一棵从栅栏里长出来的刺槐树苗。这里没有垒包，只有一块弯曲的橡胶片当作投手丘。这里的情况就是这样。任何有钱的人都会开车把孩子带到较富裕的社区去玩，留给鲍比球队这块畸形的场地。
Come on, man. I'm not going to tell you where it's going, but I want you to bring it home when it comes to you. Wake up! Wake up.
“来吧，伙计。我不告诉你球会往哪儿飞，但我希望球到你那儿时你能把它带回家。醒醒！醒醒。”
I thought you was talking to--
“我还以为你在跟我说话——”
That's what I'm saying, see. The guy in the game, the batter's not going to tell you where the ball is going, guys.
“我就是这么说的，你看。比赛里的人，击球手不会告诉你球会往哪儿飞的，伙计们。”
Talent level-- Bad News Bears. They're horrible, as far as talent. I think they're wonderful kids, and I'm not going to give up on them. But God, man. They can't throw a ball, they can't catch a ball, they can't hit a ball, and they've never learned. No one's ever taught them.
天赋水平——《坏消息熊》球队。就天赋而言，他们太烂了。我认为他们是很棒的孩子，我不会放弃他们。但天哪，伙计。他们不会投球，不会接球，不会击球，而且他们从来没学过。从来没有人教过他们。
Bring it home.
“带回家。”
[PING]
[砰]
Ah, OK. You've got good stop, good throw. That's the way to play, fella. That's the way to play. You think it's coming your way?
啊，好吧。你接得好，传得好。那是打球的样子，小子。那是打球的样子。你觉得球会往你那儿来吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah?
是吗？
I'm back in the field and got a new ball.
我回到场上，拿到了个新球。
Heads, heads up.
“注意，注意。”
The third practice starts around 5 o'clock on a humid April afternoon. Kids are scattered around the field, squatting down, twirling their gloves. Joey is throwing rocks at his brother. Joey is always throwing rocks. Benjamin thinks he should be pitching. Bobby tells him to stay right where he is and keep catching.
第三次练习在潮湿的四月下午5点左右开始。孩子们分散在场地上，蹲着，转动着手套。乔伊正在朝他哥哥扔石头。乔伊总是扔石头。本杰明认为他应该当投手。鲍比告诉他留在原地继续接球。
That's what I'm talking about right there. Come on, Benjamin. Get that thing, man. Get that ball.
“我说的就是那个。来吧，本杰明。接住它，伙计。接住那个球。”
You know.
你知道的。
Get in front of that ball.
“挡在球的前面。”
Oh, you didn't know.
“哦，你不知道。”
I do know. You need to learn. Get in front of that ball. Bring it home.
“我知道。你需要学习。挡在球的前面。把它带回家。”
After a half hour, things start to spin out of control. Benjamin, the most volatile of the kids, throws a rock at Joey. Bobby tells him to run a lap. You must be tripping, says Benjamin. I might be tripping, but you need to be lapping, says Bobby.
半小时后，情况开始失控。孩子们中最反复无常的本杰明朝乔伊扔了一块石头。鲍比叫他去跑一圈。“你一定是疯了，”本杰明说。“我可能是疯了，但你需要去跑圈，”鲍比说。
You going to make me run a lap, and I ain't even throw nothing.
“你要让我跑一圈，我又没扔什么。”
Maybe you need exercise.
“也许你需要锻炼一下。”
Benjamin-- he's my favorite because I just see me more so than any other child on that team. I don't know what his home life is like, but from what I can see, he's emotional, and when he feels cheated or done wrong, he reacts exactly like I always reacted-- violently, verbally with the violence. And he just goes off-- and fuck you and fuck the team and-- well, that's me. That was me, and in ways, it still is. When I get my feelings hurt, I don't always say, well, you really hurt my feelings. I say fuck you, motherfucker. And you know what I do? What I've done for a lot of years is I would hurt myself because someone hurt me. Well, Benjamin does that at practice.
本杰明——他是我的最爱，因为比起队里任何其他孩子，我从他身上看到了更多的自己。我不知道他的家庭生活是什么样，但从我所能看到的，他情绪化，当他感到被欺骗或做错了事时，他的反应和我以前的反应一模一样——暴力，言语上的暴力。他会大发雷霆——去你的，去这个球队，等等——嗯，那就是我。那是过去的我，在某种程度上，现在依然是。当我的感情受到伤害时，我并不总是说，好吧，你真的伤害了我的感情。我说去你的，混蛋。你知道我做了什么吗？很多年来我一直在做的事就是伤害我自己，因为别人伤害了我。嗯，本杰明在练习时也是这样。
No, man, he always getting up on my nerves. Shit. Getting on everybody's nerves.
“不，伙计，他总是惹我心烦。该死。惹得每个人都心烦。”
Bobby finally asked Benjamin to go home and come back next practice. Instead, Benjamin stands over my microphone and starts calling the game as he says it.
鲍比终于让本杰明回家，下一次练习再来。本杰明却站在我的麦克风前，开始现场直播他所看到的比赛。
He thinks he's right all the time.
“他以为他总是对的。”
Who are you talking about?
“你在说谁？”
The coach! He always-- he pressed, oh, I've been in the penitentiary. I know all this stuff. Man, bump all that, man.
“教练！他总是——他一直说，哦，我在监狱里待过。我知道所有这些东西。伙计，去你的吧，伙计。”
Bobby pauses as Benjamin mimics him, then throws the ball up and cracks it to the outfield.
当本杰明模仿他时，鲍比停顿了一下，然后把球扔起来，重重地打向外野。
Bring it home, fellas, bring it home.
“带回家，伙计们，带回家。”
A few minutes later, Benjamin finally does a lap, but he walks it.
几分钟后，本杰明终于跑了一圈，但他走完了全程。
Watch the hop. You've still got him. Good throw now, Monty. Thank you, thank you.
“注意那个弹跳。你还没输。好传，蒙蒂。谢谢，谢谢。”
When he has these kids' ages, Bobby ran wild at night, taking money, stealing bikes. Most kids were afraid of him, but he never messed with me and my brothers. I even remember Bobby and his sister eating with us a couple of times because his mom never made dinner. When Bobby was 13, his mother caught him stealing change out of her purse and kicked him out of the house. The only place Bobby knew to go was right here to this field, where he now coaches baseball.
当他像这些孩子这么大时，鲍比晚上四处游荡，偷钱，偷自行车。大多数孩子都怕他，但他从没惹过我和我兄弟。我甚至记得鲍比和他姐姐有时会和我们一起吃饭，因为他妈妈从来不做晚饭。鲍比13岁时，他母亲发现他偷她钱包里的零钱，就把他赶出了家门。鲍比唯一知道去的地方就是这里，就是这片他现在教棒球的场地。
You've got one more shot at it.
“你还有一次机会。”
It used to be an abandoned lot full of old cars and refrigerators. Here in the left outfield, where Joey is pacing and muttering because Bobby told him to quit looking for a fight-- right here, there used to be a white '69 Ford Falcon. That's where Bobby went when his mother threw him out.
它以前是一块堆满旧车和冰箱的废弃地。就在左外野这里，乔伊正因为鲍比叫他别再找茬而踱步嘟囔的地方——就在这儿，曾经有一辆白色的69年福特猎鹰。那是鲍比被母亲赶出来后的去处。
I spray painted all the windows black so no one could see in, and I would shoplift food from the corner store-- the Maddie's delicatessen, neighborhood deli. Stuff like Vienna sausages and a bottle of wine to go to sleep with at night and sardines. And that was dinner.
“我用喷漆把所有窗户都涂黑，没人能看见里面，我会从街角的商店——麦迪熟食店，社区熟食店——偷食物。像维也纳香肠，还有一瓶睡前喝的葡萄酒，还有沙丁鱼。那就是晚餐。”
Bobby says that alcohol helped him feel less afraid late at night in that old Ford. Soon, he found pot, then PCP. In his 20s, he started shooting heroin.
鲍比说，酒精帮助他在深夜待在那辆旧福特里时没那么害怕。很快，他发现了大麻，然后是PCP。在他20多岁时，他开始注射海洛因。
Sorry, you little, big-headed, little kid. Like a whole bunch of little leprechauns running around.
“抱歉，你这个大头小鬼。像一群小妖精在跑来跑去。”
Trash is talked at every practice, and Bobby is teased relentlessly for wearing Payless shoes, which the kids would never be caught dead in. Brandon, the 8-year-old, calls Bobby powdered donut because he's white, and he likes to lean into Bobby and whisper, punk. Mostly, Bobby laughs. Other times, though, especially when the kids start in on each other, it can get to him.
每次练习都有人在喷垃圾话，而鲍比因为穿了一双Payless廉价鞋而遭到无情的嘲笑，孩子们绝对不会穿那种鞋出门。8岁的布兰登称鲍比为“粉甜甜圈”，因为他是白人，而且他喜欢凑到鲍比身边小声说：“混蛋。”大多数时候，鲍比会笑。但其他时候，尤其是当孩子们开始互相攻击时，这真的会让他受不了。
Fellas, fellas, I can't talk if you're talking.
“伙计们，伙计们，如果你们在说话，我就没法说话。”
Pusher needs some more gloves, man.
“我们要更多的手套，伙计。”
I'm about ready to put the gloves in the bag and go home. Give me this stuff. Let me roll. That's yours, right?
“我准备好把手套扔进包里回家了。给我这些东西。让我走吧。那是你的，对吧？”
No, man. No, man.
“不，伙计。不，伙计。”
I'm serious. Well, shut up. Everybody shut up, please.
“我是认真的。好吧，闭嘴。大家都闭嘴，好吗？”
Bobby picks up the bat bag and slams it against the brick wall.
鲍比拿起球棒包，猛地撞向砖墙。
[BANGING]
[砰砰声]
Chill, OK? Chill. I can't talk if you're all talking. OK, look here. I'm sorry--
“冷静，好吗？冷静。如果你们都在说话，我就没法说话。好吧，看这儿。我很抱歉——”
What's up, fellas? What's happening?
“怎么了，伙计们？发生什么事了？”
Somewhere around the third or fourth practice, without announcing it in any way, the boys start calling Bobby "coach." Coach, can you fix this glove? Coach, which bat should I use?
大约在第三或第四次练习时，没经过任何预告，孩子们开始叫鲍比“教练”。“教练，你能修好这个手套吗？”“教练，我该用哪根球棒？”
What's it like when the kids call you Coach?
当孩子们叫你“教练”时，是什么感觉？
You know, I had no-- it didn't really hit me at first, you know? I took them to a picnic a couple of weekends ago that some recovering alcoholic and addict friends of mine threw. And to hear people there-- hey, Bobby, hey, Bobby, and then to hear this group of kids that I came with-- hey, Coach, hey, Coach. That's when it sort of hit me that, hey, man, that's who you are. And these people now see me as Coach, not just Bobby, the recovering drug-- dope fiend. He's Coach. So that makes me feel good to have these kids call me Coach.
你知道，我没有任何——起初我真的没反应过来，你知道吗？几个周末前我带他们去参加一个聚会，是我的一些康复中的酗酒和吸毒的朋友举办的。听到那里的人说——嘿，鲍比，嘿，鲍比，然后听到我带来这群孩子说——嘿，教练，嘿，教练。那时我才恍然大悟，嘿，伙计，那才是你。这些人现在视我为教练，不仅仅是鲍比，那个康复中的毒瘾者。他是教练。所以让这些孩子叫我教练，感觉真好。
So I don't know. Now I have this little small part and shape in what their day is going to be like, you know?
所以我不知道。现在我在他们的一天会是什么样这件事上，有了一小部分塑形的作用，你知道吗？
When he told me that he had come from prison and he got shot in his neck, I thought he was just another one of them people who like to talk about their life and didn't get over it. But I learned to understand him.
当他告诉我他来自监狱，脖子上还中过枪时，我以为他只是那种喜欢谈论自己生活却无法走出来的人之一。但我学会了理解他。
How do you understand him?
你怎么理解他？
He don't want no trouble. He just wants us to listen to him. But I guess as you grow into people, you start to have more patience.
他不想惹任何麻烦。他只是想让我们听他说。但我想当你和人相处久了，你就会开始有更多的耐心。
As you roll into people?
当你和人混在一起时？
Grow. Start to have more patience, and I think that's what's happening.
“一起成长。开始有更多耐心，我想这就是正在发生的事情。”
The Department of Recreation gives Bobby an ID badge, which he wears around his neck when he comes down to the neighborhood, like a sign. I am no longer a dope fiend. I'm doing something good. Most people might keep it in their pocket. Bobby wears it right on his chest.
娱乐部给了鲍比一个身份证章，他来到社区时会挂在脖子上，像个标志。我不再是个毒瘾者了。我正在做些好事。大多数人可能会把它放在口袋里。鲍比直接把它挂在胸前。
I just walk around with my head high and feeling proud for the most part, very proud of what I'm doing.
“我只是昂着头四处走动，在大多数情况下感到自豪，对我正在做的事感到非常自豪。”
The skeptics are everywhere, though-- neighbors who gave him advances for paint jobs he never did, people he stole bank cards from, people he actually spit on.
当然，怀疑者无处不在——那些给他预付了油漆费却没拿到活的邻居，他偷过银行卡的人，他曾经吐过口水的人。
What is that like for you to walk around in the neighborhood? And you might even walk by somebody that you owe money to or conned money out of.
走在社区里对你来说是什么样的感觉？你甚至可能会经过某个你欠他钱，或者从他那儿骗过钱的人。
It's hard to explain, really. It's a roller coaster of emotions, you know? There's times-- and right when I'm feeling like the world is wonderful, when everything is going my way, I'll see someone that I had conned out of a few hundred bucks. And the voice in my head will immediately say, see there? You're still a scumbag. Remember what-- look. That's who you really are.
很难解释，真的。这是情绪的过山车，你知道吗？有的时候——就在我感觉世界很美好，一切都很顺利的时候，我会看到某个被我骗了几百美元的人。我脑子里的声音会立刻说，看见了吗？你依然是个败类。记得吗——看。那才是真正的你。
So what do you do when you see that person?
那么当你看到那个人时，你会怎么做？
It depends. It depends on how I feel, and there's times when I might be feeling really insecure, and I'll put that macho thing up. And I'll put the cocky thing up and hope they say something wrong to me, so that I can go south with my-- you know? So--
看情况。取决于我的感受，有的时候我会感到非常不安，我会端出那种硬汉架子。我会摆出那副傲慢的态度，希望他们对我出言不逊，这样我就可以随着我的——你知道吗，往下滑？所以——
Do you do that?
你会那么做吗？
No, but I want to. I want to. I mean, there's a part of me that still wants to be a thug, you know? There's a part of me still very capable of being a thug, you know? I just wouldn't be able to be a real good thug with my hands because I'm older. I'd have to get a weapon now, you know?
不，但我很想。我很想。我是说，我内心还有一部分依然想做一个小混混，你知道吗？我内心有一部分依然非常有能力成为小混混，你知道吗？只是因为我年纪大了，我的手可能没法再做一个很好的小混混了。我现在得搞个武器，你知道吗？
I ain't wearing no girly junk, man.
“我才不穿那种娘炮垃圾，伙计。”
It's early May, and after 10 practices, the kids are finally stepping into their uniforms at the local recreation center. This is the first new thing they've seen all season. Their bats and gloves are splintered and old, but the uniforms are bright blue and gray-- Texas Ranger uniforms with red caps. Bobby is tanned and relaxed, dancing around, faking jabs, counting the kids to see if he can field the team. Never a sure thing. Today, there are exactly nine boys-- the day of their first game against another team.
五月初，经过10次练习，孩子们终于在当地娱乐中心穿上了他们的队服。这是他们整个赛季见到的第一件新东西。他们的球棒和手套破旧不堪，但队服是鲜亮的蓝灰色——带有红色帽子的德州游骑兵队服。鲍比晒得黝黑且放松，跳来跳去，假装出拳，数着孩子，看看能不能凑够人数上场。这从来都不是确定的事。今天，正好有九个男孩——这是他们对阵另一支球队的第一场比赛的日子。
The recreation bus is an hour late to take the team to their game, so some of us go in a taxi-- six kids and I all squished together. Bobby and the others are hailing a cab when the bus finally shows up. We all pile out at what is supposedly the best Little League field in the city. The grass is shin high, there's a pile of dirt in the outfield. No fans, no parents-- just Bobby and the team.
娱乐中心的巴士晚了一个小时来接球队去比赛，所以我们中的一些人坐了出租车——六个孩子和我挤在一起。当巴士终于出现时，鲍比和剩下的人正在拦车。我们都下车来到据说是城里最好的小联盟球场。草长到了小腿高，外野有一堆土。没有球迷，没有家长——只有鲍比和球队。
They don't even have a field I can slide on.
“他们甚至连个让我滑垒的场地都没有。”
Hey, what time is it?
“嘿，几点了？”
6:00, about five of 6:00.
“6点，快6点了。”
Dang, man.
“该死，伙计。”
Oh, the other team-- 4:50.
“哦，对方球队——4:50。”
The other team never shows, so Bobby's team wins by default. Some other kids are in the same boat, so there's an impromptu scrimmage. And official or not, this is the first baseball game that most of these kids have ever played.
对方球队一直没来，所以鲍比的球队获胜。其他一些孩子也遇到了同样的情况，所以来了一场即兴比赛。不管正式与否，这是这些孩子大多玩过的第一场棒球赛。
They too dang small, man. We would tear them up.
“他们太小了，伙计。我们会撕碎他们的。”
Uh-huh, OK, we suck, shut up, uh-huh, OK.
“呃哼，好，我们很烂，闭嘴，呃哼，好的。”
The other team is small, but very fast, and they have three coaches who tell them when to steal bases. So a line drive becomes a run, then another run, and another run, and it's 5-0.
对方球队很小，但速度非常快，他们有三个教练在指挥什么时候盗垒。所以一个平飞球变成了一分，又是一分，再是一分，变成了5比0。
He stole home on y'all.
“他在你们所有人面前盗了本垒。”
Good play, good play, Carlos.
“好球，好球，卡洛斯。”
That's all right. We'll see what we need to work on today, instead of looking good in our uniforms. Come on, let's get an out. We got a force at second. Get the force at second.
“没关系。我们要看看今天需要改进什么，而不是只追求制服穿起来好看。来吧，我们争取一个出局。二垒有封杀。争取二垒的封杀。”
The season lurches forward with DC Recreation canceling games for no reason, never rescheduling rain outs. The uniforms are not washed for three weeks, and one day, no one shows up to let the boys in to suit up for a game, so they have to forfeit.
赛季艰难地推进，特区娱乐部无缘无故取消比赛，从未重新安排因雨停赛的比赛。队服三周没洗，有一天，没人来给男孩们开门让他们准备比赛，所以他们不得不弃权。
By June, Bobby's team has only played one real game, one game in four months. In this inconsistent world, Bobby is someone the kids can count on. He never misses practice, coming in his painter's pants most days to hit the ball to them. And while it might seem like Bobby's keeping the kids in line, he'll tell you that's what they're doing for him.
到了六月，鲍比的球队只打了一场真正的比赛，四个月里的一场。在这个不稳定的世界里，鲍比是孩子们可以依靠的人。他从不缺席训练，大部分日子穿着他的油漆工裤子来给他们击球。虽然看起来好像是鲍比在管理孩子们，但他会告诉你，是他们在他身上起到了作用。
I don't want to have to avoid my neighborhood. I don't want to have to avoid my community playground because I let these kids down because I'm a drunken dope fiend fucking bum, which is what I become if I go have a beer right now or some dope right now. Tomorrow, I'm a bum because all the good feelings are gone.
我不想不得不避开我的社区。我不想不得不避开我们的社区操场，因为我让这些孩子失望了，因为我是个酗酒的毒瘾混蛋，如果我现在去喝杯啤酒或吸点毒，我就会变成那样。明天，我就是个烂人，因为所有美好的感觉都消失了。
I don't want to feel the shame, which I felt from relapses. And that's a big time shame. It's a shame. I won't be able to look these kids in their eyes, in their faces. I'll duck them. God, I'm 42 years old, and I would have to come in my own neighborhood and duck children because I'm ashamed. I don't want that.
我不想感受复吸带来的羞耻，那是长期的羞耻。这是耻辱。我无法看着这些孩子的眼睛，他们的脸。我会躲着他们。上帝，我都42岁了，我必须回到我自己的社区，躲着孩子们，因为我感到羞耻。我不想要那样。
Throw that smoke. Throw that smoke. Throw that smoke. You're the man out there. You're the man.
“扔出那个烟球。扔出那个烟球。扔出那个烟球。你是那儿的佼佼者。你是那个人。”
By June, Bobby's team gets its first win with some great pitching from Donald and a catch by Ricardo in the third inning that looks more like a football interception.
到了六月，鲍比的球队取得了第一场胜利，唐纳德投球出色，里卡多在第三局的接球看起来更像橄榄球拦截。
Oh, yeah! Woo! Yeah! Oh, man! Boy, that was a Major League catch, man! I don't make catches like that. Woo!
“哦，耶！呜！耶！哦，伙计！天哪，那是一个大联盟式的接球，伙计！我都做不出那种接球。呜！”
And while they wait for their bus to take them back home, the boys start tussling with each other, rolling around on a grassy hill.
当他们等待巴士带他们回家时，男孩们开始互相扭打，在草坡上滚来滚去。
They're celebrating their win.
他们在庆祝他们的胜利。
They are celebrating their win by wrestling. I'm about to myself!
他们正在通过摔跤来庆祝胜利。我自己也差点这么做了！
This is easily the sweetest moment of the season, not only because of the win, but because it's amazing to see the boys so happy. And this is what Bobby will remember-- when Justin and Ricardo get in a real fight an hour later, when he has to suspend Benjamin not once, but twice, and when Joey threatens to beat up a kid from another team. Always that delicate balance-- fragile, like sobriety.
这是本赛季最甜蜜的时刻，不仅仅因为胜利，更因为看到男孩们如此快乐简直太神奇了。这就是鲍比会记住的——当贾斯汀和里卡多在一小时后真的打起架来时，当他不得不不仅一次，而是两次停赛本杰明时，以及当乔伊威胁要殴打另一支球队的孩子时。总是那种微妙的平衡——脆弱，就像清醒一样。
Time out, time out. Let me-- I've got to tie my shoe.
“暂停，暂停。让我——我得系一下鞋带。”
I always thought I was going to be a loser forever. Man, first of all, being clean makes me feel like, OK, I got a chance to be a winner. But the kids, especially-- and something about kids. This is something I never thought, man, that I'd be able to do. It's like-- man, I was walking after a practice like a week or two ago. I swear to God I walked across Duke Ellington Bridge to the subway, and I started crying. I started crying because I was so fucking happy. You know? So happy that, damn, this is probably going to work out. I'm probably going to be able to pull this off.
我一直以为我会永远是个失败者。伙计，首先，戒毒让我觉得，好吧，我有机会成为一个赢家。但孩子们，尤其是——关于孩子们的某种东西。这是我从没想过的事情，伙计，我居然能做到。就像——伙计，一两个星期前练习后我走着，我敢对上帝发誓，我走过杜克·艾灵顿大桥去坐地铁，然后我开始哭。我开始哭，因为我太他妈高兴了。你知道吗？太高兴了，该死，这大概会成功。我大概能完成这件事。
By the end of the season, the kids have a record of two wins and no losses. Playoffs never get scheduled, so there's no reason to practice anymore. No one knows where Benjamin is these days, and just this week, I saw Joey stealing a soda from the corner store, and I made him take it back.
赛季结束时，孩子们有两胜零负的记录。季后赛从未安排，所以没理由再练习了。没人知道本杰明这些天在哪儿，就在这周，我看到乔伊在街角商店偷汽水，我让他把它送回去。
Bobby still comes around, though, and hangs out in the park, talks with the boys, and he sometimes shoots one on one with them. And he says, stick with me. I'm going to have tryouts for a 12 and under basketball team. I'm going to still be coming around here.
鲍比还是会过来，在公园里晃悠，和男孩们聊天，有时还会和他们打一对一。他说：“跟着我。我准备给12岁以下的篮球队搞选拔赛。我还会一直到这儿来的。”
Oh, you're going to get it now.
“哦，你现在要倒霉了。”
[YELLING]
[叫喊声]
Katie Davis throws that smoke in the neighborhood she grew up in in Washington, DC. It's been years since we first broadcast this story over a decade ago. Bobby did go on to coach a basketball team, and they took first place at a local Boys and Girls Club. But Bobby also relapsed. He started doing heroin again. And then he would get clean, and then he would relapse again. Then he moved to a halfway house, a sober house, where a few years back, he died. He was clean. His counselor said that one of his few possessions when he died was a CD with this story on it.
凯蒂·戴维斯在她成长的华盛顿特区社区里“掷出了烟球”。距离我们十多年前首次播出这个故事已经过去了很多年。鲍比确实继续担任篮球队教练，他们在当地一个男孩女孩俱乐部获得了第一名。但鲍比也复吸了。他又开始吸食海洛因。然后他会康复，然后再复吸。然后他搬到了一个过渡之家，一个戒毒所，几年前，他在那里去世了。他是清醒的。他的咨询师说，他去世时留下的少数财产之一，就是一张刻有这个故事的CD。
Web programs produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for today's show-- Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margie Rockland, Elise Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and conciliary Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachman, Mary Wiltenburg, and Anna Martin. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Mixing help today from Katherine Rae Mondo and Stowe Nelson. Producing help from Alvin Melathe.
今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我制作，苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德共同参与。今天节目的特约编辑——保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克兰、伊丽莎·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼、玛丽·威尔滕伯格和安娜·马丁提供了制作帮助。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。今天凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多和斯托·尼尔森提供了混音帮助。阿尔文·梅拉西提供了制作支持。
Special thanks today to Marion Roach, Cheryl Miller, Bob Cargee, Robert Kershner, Wesley Lowery, and John O'Leary. Enrico Togneri, the forensic criminologist you heard near the top of the show-- he died years ago. Our web site, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 stories for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was showing me around his gardening shed. He showed me his shears, his hand pruner, has shovels, and-- I don't know-- this thing filled with soil.
今天特别感谢玛丽恩·罗奇、谢丽尔·米勒、鲍勃·卡吉、罗伯特·克什纳、韦斯利·洛厄里和约翰·奥利里。你在节目开始时听到的法医犯罪学家恩里科·托格内里——他几年前去世了。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600个故事的档案。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他带我参观了他的园艺棚。他给我看了他的剪刀、修枝剪、铲子，还有——我不知道——那个装满土的东西。
That is a dirtbag. Straight up.
那是个邋遢鬼。没跑了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。